Okay now that we've talked through
a few examples of goals and
metrics to track, let's go
through a few scenarios together.
I want you to match the following goals
with the best metric options you see
below, by writing the corresponding
letter in the boxes you'll see.
First, for learntofly.com,
your goal is to increase qualified
traffic to your website for
your flight school business by
10% each month for six months.
And we want to increase traffic to be
from people who can actually afford
flying lessons and who have time
to devote to flying lessons.
Okay, now for
the second scenario movieman.com,
you have a video streaming service and
you notice that 30% of the people
are dropping off after the first month.
Your goal is to decrease drop off
by 20% over the next four months.
You're metric options are A,
Traffic increase.
B, Retention rate.
C, Conversions.
D, Sign ups.
Fill in the boxes with
the corresponding letters.